tête de l'union européenne pour accorder
leurs violons sur un plan de relance de
l'économie post corona venus au final
les 500 milliards d'euros de subventions
ont été revues à la baisse
il est soulagé emmanuel macron il doit
s'exprimer dans le jt de tf1 à 20 heures
la crainte d'une seconde vague en france
toujours là c'est cela peut arriver
ce sera à l'automne selon le président
du conseil scientifique de virus
viendrait du sud sourit jean-françois
delfraissy qui appelle au respect des
gestes barrière par rapport à ailleurs
l'état va relancer la distribution de
masques gratuits pour les plus précaires
une annonce d'olivier ferrand le
ministre de la santé qui attend que le
ségur de la santé aujourd'hui
et puis au royaume uni les députés la
commission parlementaire de
renseignement et de la sécurité ont
publié un rapport sur l'ingérence russes
présumés dans la campagne du référendum
sur le rexy
ne se sont pas parus nous à mettre en
évidence des preuves
moscou a toujours nié toute implication
dans ce dossier
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur rt france
et vous nous rejoignez chien au terme
d'un sommet marathon quatre jours et
quatre nuits les dirigeants de l'union
européenne se sont finalement mis
d'accord sur les modalités du plan de
relance poste au corps d'un virus et il
a fallu vaincre les réticences des pays
dits frigo pour adopter ce plan la copie
a donc été corrigée elle et précision
avec un clément hospital quatre jours et
autant de nuits de discussion pour
décrocher au petit matin un accord un
plan de relance post coronavirus obtenu
au rabais après une bataille acharnée
entre d'un côté les pays dits frugaux
menées par les pays bas et de l'autre le
couple franco allemand
le projet initial prévoyait une
enveloppe de 750 milliards d'euros
composé de 250 milliards d'euros de
prêts et surtout des dons à hauteur de
500 milliards
l'accord final revoit à la baisse la
part des subventions fixé dorénavant à
390 milliards d'euros les 360 milliards
restants seront disponibles pour des
prêts remboursables pas des
bénéficiaires données - pour prêter plus
donc un deal qui semble convenir au
médiateur du sommet charles michel cet
élan massif qui est injectée au train de
750 milliards d'euros qui vont venir
soutenir la relance économique mais pas
seulement la relance économique qui ont
voir soutenir la transformation du
projet européen je voudrais vraiment
vous dire avec beaucoup de sobriété mais
aussi beaucoup de détermination et de
conviction que cette décision qui est
prise aujourd'hui elle va transformer le
visage du projet européen très
durablement satisfaction après cette
concession faite aux pays réticents à
adopter le plan de relance initial
emmanuel macron à l'origine de cette
proposition avec angela merkel salue
également un accord historique pour
l'union européenne
le plan de relance fondée sur cette
solidarité européenne c'est un
changement historique de notre europe et
de notre zone euro c'est la première
fois que nous mettons en place cette
capacité budgétaire commune à ce niveau
là en la basant sur une capacité
d'endettement commun pour des projets
nouveaux
et en dessinant la perspective de
ressources budgétaires propres
la dernière proposition de charles
michel prévoit une hausse substantielle
des rabais accordés au frigo ces pays
jugent leur contribution nette au budget
de lieux disproportionnée les compromis
trouvés ces derniers jours ont donc
permis de décrocher cet accord les
accords qui ont été conclus permettront
aux pays de suivre pas à pas les progrès
des réformes
il ya beaucoup d'argent en jeu et c'est
bien que cela se soit fait en bons nord
il a également été convenu qu avant que
l'argent soit distribué les états
membres pour déterminer sur la base des
évaluations faites par la commission si
les recommandations sur les fonds
recouvrés ou été suivi
de son côté le premier ministre italien
giuseppe compter affirme être satisfait
de l'objectif atteint après l'accord
trouvé
l'approbation de ce plan renforce
l'action du gouvernement italien car
elle nous permet de disposer de
ressources financières importantes pour
atteindre les objectifs que nous avons
déjà identifié et que nous allons
maintenant réalisé après des moments
très tendue lors de ce sommet cette
émission de dette commune contribue pour
la première fois dans l'histoire
européenne aux objectifs climatiques un
accord sur un plan de relance acquis aux
forceps beaucoup d'incertitudes et la
peur d'un échec cristallisé l'attention
retour sur ces négociations en images
[Musique]
me
et pour des vivres qu'habitant président
de l'université franco-allemande cet
accord de 750 milliards d'euros il est
primordial pour surmonter la crise du
coronavirus écoutez moi c'est d'abord
une victoire pour l'europe qui a su à
travers quatre jours de marathon et
votre sujet l'a rappelé beaucoup d'eux
de diversité de points de vue qui a su
malgré tout arriver à un accord pour
mettre en place un plan de relance tout
à fait substantiel de 500 à 750
milliards d'euros pour aider les
ensembles des états membres de l'union
européenne à surmonter cette crise très
importante qui est là la crise du coc
vide pour appeler que les états unis ont
mis en place à un plan de 2000 milliards
d'euros et donc le plan de 750 milliards
d'euros qui est porté par l'europe est
une réponse je crois très adaptée alors
vous l'avez dit ça ne s'est pas fait
simplement je crois qu'il faut un peu
distingué sur cette question deux choses
la question du du fonds économique la
nécessité de mettre en place un plan de
réponse de relancer sur ce sujet je
crois que c'est vraiment une réussite
et puis d'autre part la question de la
gouvernance de l'union européenne qui
présentent des avantages et des
inconvénients et l'hypothèse une
deuxième vague épidémique plus que
jamais au premier plan est en tout cas
la crainte du président du conseil
scientifique pour qui nouvelle vague
pourrait arriver à l'automne trois
scénarios resterait possible d'après
jean françois delfraissy a invité sur
bfm tv aujourd'hui écouter le plus la
plus probable
c'est en effet la deuxième bac c'est à
dire qu'on est un vrai retour du virus
arrivant du sud pour la période
d'octobre novembre décembre et de son
côté des ministres de la santé et veyran
annoncé nouvelle distribution de masques
gratuits sur la question des masques
monsieur le député je voulais vous dire
que l'état ato distribué 5 millions de
masques gratuits par semaine via les css
par les communes que nous allons
réenclencher cette distribution de
masques gratuits à destination du public
précaire notamment le public qui
bénéficient de la complémentaire santé
solidaire et que par ailleurs deux
millions de français ceux qui sont
porteurs de fragilité peuvent se faire
rembourser les masques chirurgicaux sur
prescription en pharmacie et sachez
qu'on soyez de corona virus ont été
recensés en bretagne 8 se situe dans le
finistère et 3 dans les côtes d'armor
depuis le 15 juillet plus de 7000 tests
ont été réalisés dans la région est la
préfète et la directrice de cabinet de
l'agencé régionale de santé à deux
bretagne lance dans l'appel à la
vigilance
nous n'avons pas de situation
inquiétante de clusters en bretagne qui
amènerait les préfets à mettre en oeuvre
des mesures prévues par le décret de
confinement partiel ce n'est pas encore
le cas
nous n'avons pas de kloster et nous
n'avons pas loin s'en faut
le situation alarmante du côté des
disponibilités en place de réanimation
en revanche ce qu'on constate c'est
qu'on a beaucoup de cas groupés liés à
des événements ou des rassemblements
privé donc c'est très très important
du coup de devoir cette situation comme
un signal qui nous rappelle encore une
fois à la vigilance le virus circule
toujours
il ne circule que par l'intermédiaire
des personnes et donc réappliquer les
gestes barrière quotidiennement et de
manière plus forte
on en vient cette mobilisation en
soutien à l'inspecteur du travail
suspendu l'homme a été mis à pied en
avril
dernier par le ministère du travail en
plein confinement il est accusé d'avoir
désobéi à sa hiérarchie pendant
l'épidémie
d'où cette manifestation cet après midi
devant le ministère des solidarités et
de la santé les précisions c'est avec
notre reporter estelle manche le
ministère du travail reproche à anthony
à smith je cite d'avoir un méconnu de
manière grave et délibérée et répétée
les instructions de l'autorité centrale
du système d'inspection du travail
concernant son action pendant l'épidémie
de covile à 19
en clair d'avoir dépassé le cadre de ses
fonctions
anthony smith est donc le nom de cet
inspecteur du travail qui avait pendant
le confinement engagé une procédure de
référé contre une entreprise rémoise
aide à domicile ils estimaient qu'elle
n'avait pas fourni assez de protection à
ses salariés pour le ministère du
travail
cette procédure a été à déclencher son
l'aval de sa hiérarchie
anthony smith a donc été a mises à pied
en avril être dernier il est convoqué
aujourd'hui en commission à
disciplinaire une mise à pied jugée
excessive par c'est un soutien à l'appel
de plusieurs syndicats un rassemblement
était donc organisé ici aux abords du
ministère de la santé c'est là que se
trouve la drh du ministère du travail
des soutiens qui réclament l'abandon de
la procédure disciplinaire je propose
d'écouter un philippe martinez de
secrétaire général de la cgt c'est
important pour trois raisons majeures la
première c'est au ministère du travail
veut sanctionner un inspecteur du
travail parce que il y a
il a dit à une entreprise il faut
protéger vos salariés
en pleine crise du coc vide il a fait
son travail
on l'accuse de trop bien faire son
travail dans une période où tout le
monde le sait il n'y avait pas de masque
quantité suffisante pour protéger les
salariés
je vois qu'aujourd'hui il avait raison
en avance puisque le masque est
obligatoire
la deuxième c'est au saut c'est une
volonté de soumettre les fonctionnaires
et des inspecteurs du travail à
l'autorité de tutelle
or le principe des fonctionnaires c'est
leur indépendance et que soit l'autorité
ils doivent faire leur travail en toute
indépendance et la troisième chose c'est
au moment où le nouveau premier nice par
beaucoup de dialogue social de la place
des syndicats ben là c'est une nouvelle
sanction vis-à-vis d'un un militant de
la cgtg était hier à la ratp c'était un
autre donc il faut joindre la parole aux
actes pourquoi s'il fait syndical est
important il faut pas sanctionner les
les militants syndicaux s'attendaient à
une volonté politique de dire de le
mettre sous tutelle les inspecteurs du
travail qui sont déjà en nombre
insuffisant et de leur dire vous ferez
votre travail comme nous à décider et
pas selon ce que vous savez selon les
lois
anthony hayes smith devrait être fixé
sur son sort dans les jours qui suivent
sachez que de précédents rassemblements
avaient été organisés en soutien à cet
inspecteur du travail à reims en juin
dernier notamment et jean luc mélenchon
également présent sur les lieux pour
soutenir cet inspecteur du travail pour
lui s est mise à pied elle est avant
tout un acte politique en écoute on
n'avait jamais vu autant de mesures
prises chaque année on compte des
personnes qui ont en charge des
fonctions d'autorité comme inspecteur du
travail
le contrôleur
dans les transports etc donc c'était
important pour nous de venir on est plus
à trois ou quatre de mon groupe
le parlementaire pour montrer à
l'autorité administrative que sont en
train de faire et politique je pense que
c'est vraiment une mesure d'intimidation
parce qu'évidemment quand vous êtes un
travailleur durand et qu'on vous dit ban
inspecteurs du travail a été puni il y
tient un inspecteur du travail est puni
jeudi la peau personnes dix mois
qu'est-ce que je vais prendre qui
régissent quoi voilà c'est fait pour un
grand vide où les directions à la
belgique avec un jour de fête nationale
durement touché par la crise de lakovic
19 le pays veut rendre hommage au
personnel soignant ainsi qu'aux victimes
de l'épidémie
la belgique qui détient le triste record
mondial de mortalité proportionnellement
au nombre d'habitants il ya une 9800
d'essai pour 64 mille cas répertoriés a
mis les défilés militaires ouvriers qui
avaient lieu célébrer les 75 ans de la
fin de la seconde guerre mondiale des
festivités particulières cette année
réduite en raison de la pandémie en
comprend sur place on observe une hausse
de plus de 60% des contaminations est
l'autorité estime que ses mains donc il
faut réagir
[Musique]
pour
tous
[Musique]
coût
et pour yvan le thème infectiologues au
chu saint-pierre de bruxelles
porte-parole interfédérale pour la ville
contre lakovic 19 la belgique a n'a pas
sous-estimer à la mortalité que vide
contrairement à d'autres pays
pour l'instant on n'a pas de risque riou
fait elle-même qui ont été extrêmement
limités par contre divers foyers qui se
sont réveillés dans le pays c'est la
première fois depuis qu'on a des confiné
pose effectivement un problème qui est
préoccupant sans être dramatique
on a des problèmes liés à des
rassemblements familiaux ou avec des
amis qui ont probablement dépasser un
petit peu le contexte où ils sont
autorisés dans le rapprochement ou dans
le nombre de personnes ils ce sont des
foyers démunis clust qui se sont formés
à 6 à différents endroits il faut donc
éviter maintenant qu'il contamine plus
largement la population tout le pays a
comptabilisé cdc de manière différente
que d'autres pays on a comptabilisé tous
les décès compatibles même nom prouver
que vite positive tout spécialement dans
les maisons de repos on a eu des
problèmes en maison de repos comme
d'autres pays effectivement dans
différentes parties du monde et ceci
nous amène un bilan qui est correspond
parfaitement à la surmortalité que nous
avions pendant ces quelques mois on n'a
pas su ou sous-estimé au surestimé par
d'autres au contraire d'autres pays qui
ont parfois sous-estimé de 40 à 50 % la
mortalité covit on en vient à cette
tension improbable entre londres et
moscou des députés britanniques a
demandé une enquête sur des allégations
d'ingérence rue sur de la campagne du
référendum sur une brique site en 2016
mais le rapport de la commission
parlementaire du renseignement et de la
sécurité n'avance aucune preuve les
explications des grégoire 10 f apporter
une réponse à la menace russe
c'est ce que préconise un rapport
parlementaire britannique d'une
cinquantaine de pages dévoilé par les
députés de la commission parlementaire
du renseignement et de la sécurité
le document n'apporte toutefois aucune
preuve tangible pas de mise en évidence
d'une ingérence ruse donc mais les
députés membres de cette commission
appelle le gouvernement britannique a
mené sa propre enquête sur la question
les indications fournies par le
gouvernement ont montré qu'il n'y avait
pas eu d'ingérence réussi dans le
processus démocratique britannique ni
d'activités ayant eu des répercussions
sur les élections notamment sur les
résultats cependant le scandale
s'explique par le fait que personne
n'avait fait de recherches à ce sujet il
n'y a pas une enquête afin qu'il puisse
faire une telle déclaration mais aucune
tentative n'ayant été faite pour
examiner les faits elle cette
déclaration était donc plutôt creuse la
diplomatie russe a immédiatement réagi
et balayé d'un revers de main ces
insinuations rien de sensationnel de la
russophobie plein de fausses nouvelles
un rapport qui intervient quelques jours
après que londres a accusé les
renseignements russes de cyber attaques
visant des laboratoires qui recherchent
un vaccin contre le coronavirus une
accusation également démentie par le
kremlin
le royaume uni n'a là non plus avancé
aucune preuve pour le moment et pour
jarjat samueli chercheurs global
institute ce qu'il faut souligner avec à
son genre de rapport c'est qu'il ne
présente jamais la moindre preuve
je propose de l'écouter le sujet avec ce
genre de rapport il ne présente jamais
la moindre près tout ce que nous avons
c'est beaucoup d'insinuations beaucoup
nous avions d'ailleurs j'ai tout fait
sur des acteurs et des actions qui
voudraient du mal à l'occident parce
qu'on demande des preuves et y en a pas
et il ya une bonne raison à cela parce
que si ce genre de rapport produit des
preuves à leur l'épreuve peut-être
peuvent être remises en question et cela
s'est déjà passé et cela a mené à une
dissolution complète du
de la présumée par exemple connivence
entre donald trump et le gouvernement
russe a été éventée donc il est beaucoup
plus pratique de sous-entend être parce
que personne ne peut les mettre ce genre
de choses en question et ils disent dans
le rapport qu'il est impossible de
publier tous les détails tous les faits
car le gouvernement suit à tout cela
d'être créé pour utiliser au fait
informations afin de lui les intérêts du
royaume uni ne pas se lancer dans cette
voie par plus que donne un truc ne le
souhaitait il ne souhaite pas enquêté
sur le résultat de cette année 2007 la
situation va continuer les associations
vont continuer que font les annales a
posté le royaume va se rendre compte
qu'il est trop tard la gérante rue dans
les sélections au centre de toutes les
préoccupations aux états unis on
s'occupe maintenant de la chine et le
royaume uni est encore un peu tôt ou
tard et essaye de rattraper
depuis 2016 et puis cette rencontre
aujourd'hui à londres entre le
secrétaire d'état américain mike pompéo
le premier ministre britannique boris
johnson une entrevue alors que le
royaume uni et la chine sont plus que
jamais en froid après avoir décidé
d'exclure à houaïlou et géant chinois
des télécoms de son réseau 5 g la
grande-bretagne suspens le traité
d'extradition avec hong kong en cause la
controversée loi de sécurité nationale
chinoise dans l'ancienne colonie
britannique les précisions avec emilie
google suspension immédiate et pour une
durée indéterminée du traité
d'extradition avec hong kong
le chef de la diplomatie britannique l'a
annoncé devant le parlement mais les
sanctions de londres ne s'arrête pas là
appliquée à la chine depuis 1989
l'embargo sur les armes potentiellement
létale a également été étendu pour être
clair l'extension de cet embargo
signifie qu'il n'y aura pas
d'exportation d'armes potentiellement
mortelle de leurs composants ou de leurs
munitions du royaume uni vers hong kong
une décision qui ne passe pas du côté de
la chine et qu'un dénonce une ingérence
de la part de londres mais aussi une
violation du droit international
les récentes remarques et mesure erronée
du royaume uni concernant kong ont
gravement enfreint le droit
international et les normes
fondamentales régissant les relations
internationales et se sont ingérés de
manière flagrante dans les affaires
intérieures de la chine
la chine condamne fermement cette
situation s'y opposent
cette nouvelle escalade des tensions
avec la chine intervient après l'entrée
en vigueur de la loi sur la sécurité
nationale à hong kong un texte promulgué
un peu plus d'un an après le début de
manifestations dénonçant l' influence du
gouvernement de l'archipel
jugé trop favorable à pékin ces
sanctions britanniques interviennent
alors que les etats-unis ont adopté des
mesures similaires
pékin a déjà accusé londres de suivre
aveuglément les américains washington
dont la décision d'exclure huawei le
géant des télécoms de son réseau 5 g a
récemment été imité par l'ong à
l'analyse de joël rey est un économiste
au cnrs et président du groupe de
réflexion un bridge bank
le problème de pékin je le disais tout à
l'heure c'est cette une question
épineuse est une question épineuse parce
que pour eux c'est une question de
souveraineté nationale
pour le parti communiste chinois en
particulier donc c'est une question de
légitimité et on sait très bien dans le
système chinois l'économie quelle
politique sont liés c'est pas comme dans
les systèmes libéraux où on essaye de
dissocier les deux dont je crois que la
mesure de rétorsion les mesures de
rétorsion peuvent aller jusqu à
l'économique et dans ce cas là il y
aurait un problème potentiel puisque je
le disais au temps les anglais s est de
dissocier les rétorsions de politique
d'une d'un côté un engagment continuent
et continuent économique dans l'autre si
pékin devait prendre des réactions
publiques
restons là ça pourrait mettre ça pour
mathis et attiser les braises c'est là
où je disais qu'on a un problème
potentiellement très importants qui
dépasse très largement les enjeux
économiques y compris politiques autour
de la seule presqu'île de hong kong
après portland dans le nord ouest des
états unis le président américain soit
envoyé des policiers fédéraux dans
d'autres villes démocrates parmi celles
ci à chicago et new york
sauf qu'à portland à la présence des
forces fédérales suscitent une
importante controverse est métropole
elle est devenue le symbole du bras de
fer entre donald trump et les
manifestants on voit ce tout cela en
images
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les gens se sont littéralement levée
dans des véhicules de location banalisés
ils ne savent pas qui les met dans les
véhicules car les policiers ne disent
pas qui ils sont pour moi c'est
contraire à la constitution
leur présence entraîne plus de violence
et plus de vandalisme cela n'aide pas du
tout à apaiser la situation
ils ne sont pas les bienvenus et nous
voulons qu'il parte
[Musique]
et c'est la fin de ce journal merci à
vous de l'avoir suivi on va se retrouver
en direct dans 30 minutes rester avec
moi total
[Musique]
levitt a été le révélateur le monstre
aux pieds d'argile que nous sommes la
france et je l'éteins elle veut devenir
veut partout mais elle n'a pas les
moyens ma critique et dames c'est que
notre continuant à nier l'évidence c'est
à dire nous continuer à mentir sur la
réalité de notre pouvoir qui est devenu
comme théâtre est ce que cette france-là
bouffer moins peur que celle que vous
avez décrite ce pape allemand dans la
france objet peur c'est 2 du ca qui
pourrait pas tenez qui pourrait être
réservé un très beau pays
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous
[Musique]
pourquoi vous maintenez le traitement à
base d'hydroquinone rockin et d'asie
trop mis 6 malgré la polémique mondiale
sur l'efficacité de cette combinaison
nous avions déjà commencé à utiliser le
protocole avec les boutiques préoccupe
bien avant que le match ne commence a
sonné chez par sénégal la chloroquine
domaniale est utilisé pendant des
décennies et des décennies ça pourrait
faire sourire les sénégalais quand
j'entendis désastreux il n'y a pas de
signes qui m'est rendu
voilà ce que j'ai trouvé
[Musique]
il
qui pense pas même reçu que vous
connaissez toutes les stars de la
planète dont c'était c'est tout c'est ce
que j'avais à dire
non pourquoi pas ce que c'est